.
Freunde der Sonne, heute geht es um
die Pharma-Verschwörung!
Aus aktuellem Anlass.
In unserer letzten Sendung
haben wir vor dem Bleichmittel,
"Heilmittel", MMS gewarnt.
Und, voila.
Die Pharma-Verschwörung geht so:
Die Pharmaindustrie
will uns gar nicht heilen.
Mit den Medikamenten,
die sie uns verkaufen.
Für viele Krankheiten
gibt es nämlich einwandfreie
und günstige Therapien.
Aber die
Pharmaindustrie möchte nicht,
dass wir davon erfahren.
Warum?
Damit sie uns weiter mittelmäßige,
aber teure Medikamente
verkaufen können.
Die zwar die Symptome bekämpfen,
aber die Krankheit nicht heilen.
Wie sonst soll die Pharmaindustrie
ihr Milliardengeschäft machen?
Holt euch einen Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich.
Denn das wird jetzt was.
Erst mal, nein, ich werde nicht
von der Pharmaindustrie bezahlt.
Sondern, viel schlimmer,
vom Rundfunkbeitrag.
Ich habe keinen persönlichen Vorteil,
wenn ich vor
"Heilmitteln" wie MMS warne.
Es sei denn...
Die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
sind Teil der Pharma-Verschwörung.
Die meisten von euch
denken sich jetzt ohnehin.
(Französisch gesprochen:) Bullshit.
Muss das "t" dabei stumm sein?
Aber habt ihr schon
mal ernsthaft versucht,
die Pharma-Verschwörung
zu diskutieren.
Zum Beispiel mit MMS-Anwendern?
Viele von euch haben es
in den Kommentaren versucht.
Aber es ist gar nicht so einfach.
Deshalb gibt es jetzt
hier fünf Hilfestellungen.
Medikamente und
Therapien sind streng reguliert.
Zuerst müssen sie
im Labor getestet werden.
Mit Zell- und Tierversuchen.
Die sind die Voraussetzung
für die klinischen Studien.
Mit hunderten von Menschen.
Die ebenfalls
durchgeführt werden müssen.
Bevor ein Medikament
überhaupt auf den Markt kommen kann.
Das Ganze dauert viele
Jahre und ist ziemlich teuer.
Es kann 1 Milliarde kosten.
Aber wir können froh sein, dass
dieser Aufwand verlangt wird.
Denn es wäre unverantwortlich,
einen Stoff für
medizinische Zwecke zu verabreichen,
der nicht sorgfältig durch
klinische Studien geprüft wurde.
Zum Unmut der Medikamenten-Hersteller
führt dieser lange und teure Prozess
oft gar nicht zu einem Produkt.
An jeder Stelle
des Entwicklungsprozesses
kann man scheitern.
Und damit viel Geld
und Arbeit in den Sand setzen.
Weil Medikamenten-Entwicklung
sehr kompliziert ist.
Weil der menschliche Körper und seine
Krankheiten sehr kompliziert sind.
Selbst wenn man es
bis zum Ende schafft,
zugelassen wird ein Medikament nur,
wenn es wirkt,
wenn die Nebenwirkungen
dabei vertretbar sind,
wenn es in irgendeiner
Hinsicht auch besser ist.
Einen Vorteil hat
gegenüber den Medikamenten,
für die entsprechende Krankheit,
die bereits auf dem Markt sind.
Durch diese
Regulierungen wird verhindert,
dass ein skrupelloser,
geldgieriger Pharmakonzern
ein unwirksames oder schädliches
Präparat auf den Markt bringt.
Und da die Entwicklung
der Medikamente so teuer ist,
ohne Erfolgsgarantie,
wären die Konzerne schön blöd,
wenn sie ein eigentlich
viel besseres Heilmittel
dem Markt fernhalten würden.
Eben weil Medikamente
so streng kontrolliert werden,
findet man in der MMS-Szene
ständig Disclaimer, wie...
Solche Hinweise heißen übersetzt:
Im Gegensatz zu einem Medikament
oder einer medizinischen Therapie
wurde hier weder etwas belegt,
noch kontrolliert oder geprüft.
Die Heilung zum Krebs
wird sehr häufig bei solchen
"Heilmitteln" versprochen.
Zunächst ist
Krebs biologisch höchst komplex.
Und es gibt auch nicht den Krebs.
Es gibt viele
verschiedene Krebs-Arten.
Denen alle verschiedene
biologische Prozesse zugrunde liegen.
Und bei manchen Krebsarten
ist die medizinische
Forschung schon weit gekommen.
Brustkrebs können heute
viele Menschen überwinden.
Warum die Pharmaindustrie hier
die Heilung nicht geheim hält?
Who knows.
Andere Krebsarten, wie
Bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs,
die enden meist tödlich.
Alle Experten, die irgendwo
auf der Welt zu Krebs forschen,
auch der gesunde Menschenverstand,
die sprechen dagegen,
dass so etwas Komplexes wie Krebs
durch eine ganz einfache,
simple Lösung zu bekämpfen ist.
Diese ganzen Heiler und Gurus
haben natürlich ihre Behauptungen.
Die allerdings nicht plausibel sind.
Die ziemlich einfach
wissenschaftlich zu widerlegen sind.
Wie wir in unserem
letzten Video gezeigt haben.
Ein beliebtes Gegenargument ist:
Die Pharmafirmen bringen
das nicht auf den Markt,
weil sie es nicht patentieren können.
Nehmen wir mal zum Spaß an,
das Bleichmittel Chlordioxid
würde tatsächlich gegen Krebs helfen.
Dann wäre es wirklich nicht ganz
einfach, das zu patentieren.
Zumindest müssten sich die
Pharmafirmen etwas einfallen lassen.
Ich denke zwar, dass
ihnen da etwas einfallen würde.
Prinzipiell kann man durchaus sagen,
dass die Pharmafirmen
keinen Anreiz hätten,
viel Geld für Forschung und
Entwicklung in die Hand zu nehmen,
wenn sie am Ende
des Patent nicht sicher haben.
Aber wenn es wirklich ernst
zu nehmende Hinweise gäbe,
dass ein Mittel X ein
revolutionärer Durchbruch
bei der Heilung
einer Erkrankung wäre,
dann gibt es nicht
nur die Pharmafirmen.
Die ganzen Unis,
die Forschungseinrichtungen
auf der ganzen Welt,
alle hätten ein
Riesen-Interesse daran.
Jeder Forscher möchte
natürlich ein Mittel
gegen eine
unheilbare Krankheit entdecken.
Oder nur dessen medizinische
Wirksamkeit wissenschaftlich belegen.
Für so etwas
werden Nobelpreise verliehen.
Für Forschungsinteressen,
die nicht wirtschaftlich sind,
gibt es so etwas wie
die "Gates Foundation",
die z.B.
Malariaforschung unterstützt.
Weil die sich für Konzerne
finanziell nicht rechnet.
Genauso wäre es bei MMS. Wenn dann
nur irgendetwas Wahres dran wäre.
Was es leider nicht ist.
Es gibt natürlich
die Pharmaindustrie.
Aber die besteht aus
vielen verschiedenen Firmen.
Die alle miteinander
in Konkurrenz stehen.
Anstatt ein Wundermittel,
ein Mittel, was alle Krebsarten
heilt, für sich zu behalten,
würde ein Konzern natürlich
viel mehr Geld verdienen,
wenn er dieses Wundermittel
einfach auf den Markt bringen würde.
Der Konzern würde sich sofort
in Monopolstellung begeben.
Weil dieses Mittel
dann auch viel besser wäre
als alles,
was bisher auf dem Markt ist.
Deswegen könnten sie es teuer
an sehr viele Menschen verkaufen.
Wenn man trotzdem glaubt,
dass alle unter einer Decke stecken,
dann muss man diesen Gedanken
auch logisch zu Ende denken.
Denn selbst wenn alle
Pharmafirmen dem Wettbewerb entsagt,
sich gemeinsam verschworen hätten,
würde der Plan noch
lange nicht aufgehen.
Die Pharmaindustrie
wird streng reguliert.
Wer das nicht glaubt,
der muss logischerweise folgern,
dass auch die Regulierungsbehörden
mit den Konzernen unter einer
Decke stecken. Aber nicht nur das.
Alle Ärzte und Krankenhäuser müssten
da irgendwie mit drin stecken.
Sowie auch alle Unis und
Forschungseinrichtungen dieser Welt.
Die medizinische Forschung betreiben.
Außerdem alle Lehrbücher der Medizin.
Auch die voller Lügen.
Das steht nirgendwo drin, dass
Autismus eigentlich heilbar ist.
Und auch alle Journalisten.
Die, wie ich, darüber berichten,
müssten entweder
unter einer Decke stecken
oder völlig geblendet sein.
Obwohl es
für Journalisten karrieretechnisch
nichts Besseres gibt, als einen
riesigen Skandal zu veröffentlichen,
wurde bisher noch nichts von
dieser Pharmaverschwörung aufgedeckt.
Und all die vielen Menschen, die
Teil dieser Verschwörung sind,
müssten
eigentlich kerngesund sein.
Sagen wir, es gäbe ein
geheimes Mittel gegen Krebs,
dann würden all die Menschen,
die Teil dieser Verschwörung sind,
auch deren Familien,
niemals Krebs bekommen.
Denn sie würden
dieses Mittel doch hoffentlich
wenigstens für sich selbst nutzen.
Oder würden sie, um die
Verschwörung zu schützen,
sich selbst und ihre
Familienmitglieder opfern?
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es
Menschen, die "Heilmittel" bewerten,
die so gut wie
keiner Kontrolle unterliegen.
Deren Wirksamkeit nicht
wissenschaftlich belegt ist.
Und doch schreiben
sie Bücher, bieten Seminare an.
Therapiesitzungen usw.
Um Geld zu verdienen.
Moment mal!
Da könnte man ja fast meinen,
dass diese Heiler nur
behaupten, dass ihre Mittel wirken,
um mit den Hoffnungen und Ängsten
von Menschen mit schwer heilbaren
Krankheiten Geld zu verdienen.
Aber was davon
ist jetzt realistischer?
Bitte
versucht
nachzudenken.
Ihr werdet in den Kommentaren,
zum Beispiel unter unserem MMS-Video,
aber auch an vielen
anderen Stellen im Netz,
immer wieder auf das Argument
der Pharmaverschwörung stoßen.
Immer, wenn es
um Wunderheilmittel geht.
In Zukunft könnt ihr
euch einfach Zeit und Mühe sparen.
Als Antwort einfach
dieses Video posten.
Your welcome.